Today's topic.
I'm Lucas. I'm Alex.
And we are.
Buddies buddies slash friends with benefits with like a asterisk,
maybe see below. Could it lead to something more?
She's wanna point out. You see how he's sitting in a chair?
Oh, uh, yes, maybe.
Yeah, maybe. Possibly. I haven't talked about it. <laugh> yeah,
we haven't talked about that about all this stuff. Um, with time. Yeah.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> okay. You go first ladies.
First. All right. What are the terms of this relationship? Whoa.
Probably, uh, should have thought about this. Um, we, uh, like each other.
We have to be friends still and then like we have tech sometimes I know we have
sex.
Sometimes. Yeah. We haven't set boundaries.
Yet. No legal documents. Yeah. No.
Contract. Y'all not friends with benefits. Y'all just messy guys.
Are you guys haven't discussed how this is supposed to go down.
You guys haven't discussed boundary whether or not you're allowed to see other
people. What those rules of engagement are. You guys are just,
you guys are waiting. You guys are waiting for this to blow up in your fix.
We'll.
Make the rules right now. <laugh> okay. <laugh> all righty.
Should we like tell the other person if we are sleeping with other.
People? Yes. Okay. Okay. Okay. There's a little bit of a look there,
but that's okay. No. Okay. Then like, okay. Yes, no, that's good. All right.
That's a good.
Good first one. So they're discussing the rule in front of everybody.
That's the first time. Okay. This is just speaks to the reality.
Like most people out here that don't know what they doing or how to talk about
it. Like you say, they, as progressive as I want or whatever,
most people are not having good conversations. No, they're not even me.
I was at that age. We did talk about that.
Most people we're not talking about it. And even today did this age.
People wouldn't really want they talking about this. They're not, they're not,
they're not listening.
Or they want to hear what they want to hear in front of a camera.
They'll say whatever. Or in front of their friends,
they'll say whatever they get behind closed door and you find out they don't do
any of the that they talk about.
Cause nothing words and friends with benefits where one of them clearly wants to
do the other. Yeah. Yeah. She wants to be the relationship with him. Yeah. Yeah.
He's the one. Who's his he's like, man. Yeah. We haven't said boundaries.
Are we.
Allowed to, um, have feelings? Yeah. We're allowed to have feelings. Okay.
That'd be.
Weird. If are we allowed to have feelings? Yeah.
Hey right on the money.
Are we allowed to Hawk and express about that person? Yeah, I think it's better.
<laugh> it's better. That way. It's better have open communication. It's.
Better that way. Yeah. Um, if we find someone else that we like,
we should probably communicate that what would happen if we got pregnant?
Wow. We would have a really heavy conversation. He would.
Find, find a kind of way to say abortion code hanger.
<laugh> he was just trying to find a good,
and we would have a long conversation about consenting,
how being an adult is gonna be very difficult considering there's no love
between us and other abortion. <laugh>.
That was, we know what, what to do. Right. And I, I mean, I, I would,
I would want to any way I can help. Yeah.
Sure. You're just gonna support.
I'm gonna support definitely favor the not having kids right now. Yeah,
absolutely. Option. Absolutely. Like 100%. <laugh> what would you do?
Uh, I probably, I would probably have an abortion for sure.
If that were to happen. Would your relationship.
End? I don't think it would end it.
I don't think so. No. Maybe it would just be like, all right.
Like we've proven that we're irresponsible right in this realm.
So let's just be friends without benefits maybe.
Yeah. But experiencing that could make you like maybe closer,
but it's also kind of how shock stop.
So maybe it's not yeah.
Hard to say on the count three stop name. Who.
Likes, who? Stop. Stop. Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Stop.
She said losing a baby could bring us together.
You are living in such delusion. God helped your soul. Get out of the,
whatever this is. It's not good for you. Okay? You are not ready to do this.
This is not for you. You're not someone who wanted to be friends with benefits.
Here's someone who settled on being friends with benefits when you didn't get
what you wanted. And it's sad to watch. And I'm not so saying this to mock you.
I'm saying this cuz it's sad. This is very, very sad. Yeah.
And one day you're gonna wash this back and read one and be like I said this,
but not only were you cringy,
but you were cringy on the internet for everyone to watch.
And I feel for you girl, I feel for you except everyone got their cringy period,
even me. But you know what? Back when I did it, we only had for lip phones.
Nobody knows nobody. I'm taking it with me to my grave.
But boo, boo,
you just said maybe us losing a baby will bring us closer together.
What the?
Maybe losing a baby will bring us close.
What? Whoa. Ugh.
Ni that's people like that. It's sad. Yeah. That's still a thing it's so sad.
Oh, it's gonna be okay.
It's not it's I promise it's gonna be okay.
There's plenty of other white dudes out there.
They don't have mustaches think like Asian girls you're gonna do better.
Believe in yourself. Are you afraid of commitment?
<Laugh> I would say yes and no. Honestly. How so?
I think I'm afraid to commit to the wrong person. Of course,
which I think everyone relate, right? Yes. I'm afraid of commitment.
Have you slept with someone else since we've been sleeping with each other.
Hooked up,
but not slept with like Soo chiro the way she was.
Looking? No, no. She was bracing herself for impact.
That's the face I do when it goes,
sucking the soul outta my Dick and I need to hold on for dear life.
Just cuz I'm like tuna. <laugh>.
Like Soo Truro type of thing. Who was it?
Yeah. Hiding that discontent. Let's go.
The fact that you called it a smoo Truro, cuz make it cuter. It does it. He,
he knows that. Humor, her smooth, everything over. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Yeah. That's a door, but she's not having any of it. Yeah. Who was there?
Yeah.
The only way to survive in this world was that kind of mustache to be funny
<laugh>.
It was a previous Tinder person from like six months ago.
They've moved to Taiwan since that's very random.
Is that? Yeah. So you were like hook up to say, bye.
See you never, she never cool. No, it was damnable.
Bit from Taiwan. Huh? <laugh> my man got a type. When he does a smoo room,
he looks that full salad.
Nah, it was damnable bit. Would you.
Have them if they initiated it, man.
Maybe.
Would you have told me?
Oh, she's not. Ooh. She, I having fun. She's not what you said.
Would you have told me? No, but he can't say that. Cuz he don't want him like.
A. I would've told you if you would've asked <laugh> so I said no, not.
Said no. She would've asked. I mean,
I would've told you if you asked me about that thing that you didn't even know
no about <laugh> you know what I'm saying? Like, yo it's like, Hey man,
you would've. You know what I'm saying? Like, yo uh,
I have a like did I steal a hundred dollars from your purse? Yeah.
Would you have told me? I mean,
if you would've asked how the would I know if you didn't tell me,
cause I would I'd catch you. I mean, you know, maybe you got superpowers,
you know what I'm saying? S SWER, Roney, baby.
Who's more attractive me or the person that went to Taiwan.
You are more attractive.
She's not even picking the carts. It's just, yo, let's go on that.
She needs to know. Yo listen, I brought yo, that was a good one. Cuz cut,
set up. Who's more attractive. You are the. You never gonna get the again.
<laugh>
yo yo you'd have to be a idiot or the with the,
his balls to answer this any other way. Yeah.
What am I gonna say? I'm gonna say no, don't not. You can say.
No <laugh> you have to be truthful.
Or your drink. So I would say yes, physically. Yes. Okay.
You're also just like much more enjoyable to hang out with as well. Thank you.
So.
What are my three worst traits?
Yeah. I'm not not doing that. <laugh> what about me? Triple booking yourself?
Yeah. One worst. Supposed to hang out. Right?
Right, right. I feel terrible about that. <laugh>.
So awful. I'm triple booking yourself. Okay.
That means that this man is feeding her like plan C. All right.
If Cindy's not down and if the is not going to Taiwan. Oh, she's gone to Taiwan.
Hey, what up? But everybody said yes. So he is like, whoops.
If a man consistently Sirone let me tell you the man consistently triple books
himself. And then he flakes on you last minute. He's not into you whatsoever.
No. Even as a friend with benefits. No, he's treating you like a,
like friend C with benefits, right? There's friend a B before.
You like, I hate it. When people do that to me,
I hate that when I do that to people. Yeah. Yeah. Uh, yeah. I apologize. Sorry.
That's okay.
When are you going to introduce me to your parents?
Hey mom.
Why? Hey,
mom's a girl. I. Sometimes.
Why can't I be your significant other?
Why can't you <laugh>.
That's why I did this whole video so I can pop this question. Why can't you,
uh.
I'm gonna take a shot of the shot. All right. Nice. Nice. Why?
Why won't it work?
I don't have the answer for that. What are all the things that could go right?
If we decided to commit to each other. Wow. That's.
A beautiful question. It's a beautiful like flowing. Yeah. Um,
what could go right? This opportunity.
Just a beautiful relationship where we're like mature and like
friends before, you know, it's like we didn't just meet on, on a dating app.
I think there is something kind of novel about that.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> where it's like, you just met like how humans met,
you know, for the past 10,000 years or whatever.
Something novel about meeting out the app.
But I'm a the girl from Taiwan though. I'm gonna just say this.
This is the cruelest thing. He could have it done up until now. I'm like, bro,
you got you. You, you, your, your hands are clean. You're good.
But you gotta know how much she's into you.
How much more she's into you than you are into her.
And you say that exactly what she wants to hear. Ooh,
but you know what?
I'm not gonna judge either of these two Le of your best lives.
I'm just saying this can't end. Well.
Could you see yourself falling in love with me?
I haven't been in love,
so I don't know.
Even like the concept of like the one and then falling in love.
Like I've loved people. I could see myself.
Loving you. Yes. But you wouldn't fall though. Not wouldn't fall.
I think I'd feel similarly. I don't think I would fall in love with you.
I got head over heels. <laugh> I don't think you have the same terminal. Yeah.
Have love for you. Mm-hmm <affirmative> yeah. How was this experience?
This was awesome. It's.
Great. No, no, no. It's sad. No, humor's fantastic.
Humor has a great way of making the difficult stuff Pala,
but there are times where you just need an honest, straight conversation.
These who need that badly. They need to have a real talk,
cuz that is gonna end terrible. That's like being on the interstate,
looking to your left and watching a bus with a clown on its front bumper
on fire,
driving in the wrong direction and just going 120 with a bunch of kids
back.
But you know you about to watch twisted metal happen right in front of you.
It is sad. We got the twisted metal reference. Did you that? Oh definitely.
Cause that's an old game. The clown with the bus. Yeah. Come on. That's a,
that's an old game. Yeah, but that's, it's a classic game.
That's a classic game. That's a classic game. I never played. And every time I,
I never, I knew somebody was gonna die. I never played that game.
And I got the reference. I'm like, is this an old reference? No,
there's a lot of young people who are not gonna know. Yeah.
They're not gonna know. Yeah. So you know, but with metal classic game,
I didn't play the game, but I knew the reference. That's my favorite driving.
That's that's it's the middle for real. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But anyways,
all this to say, man, it's just,
if you guys are gonna do the principal benefits thing, have the conversation.
Okay. I know it might be difficult. It might be complicated. I know. Okay.
It's awkward to, you know,
negotiate terms of sex and like have these candid conversations.
But trust me when things go south,
you're gonna be grateful that you talked about it. If she gets per by accident.
Well, at least you guys have discussed it.
So you have a point of reference and you won't be blindsided when this happened.
You still might. But at the very, at least, you know,
you did your due diligence. Okay? Cover your basis.
Talk about how you would feel if you saw them with the other person.
Be honest with yourself and be honest with them. Cause when here's the fan,
people ask me, how do you have friends with benefits for so long?
It didn't end be we had conversations after cuz I it up before.
I didn't want to get up again. So just having those talks makes it a lot easier.
So that's my advice.
He's in deep and he thinks cracking a joke is gonna solve everything.
It doesn't solve everything. That's some point gonna have to talk about it,
but whatever. Yeah. Someone says they so obviously like each other. No, he,
he is not into her Uber. He's not, he's not that into her. Oh my God.
People really can't see what's happening out. No, no they can't.
He definitely wants to be with her. Just following her vibes.
People are not that smart. Common sense is not that common people really think.
Yeah. He she's afraid to commit the wrong person. Yeah. And he's,
he's the one that really wants to fall in love with her. He's like, yeah,
he's something else. He's really, he really wants to be with her.
And but why he's really, really turned and he likes her,
he's exercising his options and he's hiding it from her and he
doesn't feel bad about it if you like the light it to yourself like that. Yeah.
People don't know what they're looking. They don't know what they're looking at.
That man's living his best life. Right. He's in diesel shape. He's out there.
He's getting legs. He's gonna keep going. Yo,
yo people have no idea what they're looking at. But anyways,
maybe you guys saw it can play different than me. Maybe you see a cute couple.
Let us know what you guys think in company. How,
how sweet where's Ja rule when we need a.
No use, nothing to do.
When you turn on
why you wanna be a
no time for big ones,
be the one that keeps you calling that you calling
call and call the.